Tim Ferriss: We have questions that
were pre-submitted and then we have
questions that are coming in on the
live feed and I'll do my best to answer
a whole bunch of both. So why don't we dive in.
The first question I'll answer is from the live
feed. This is from Zahir. "Are you actively taking
any actions to reduce your carbon footprint?"
Yes, I am. There are certainly a number
of different steps you can take in terms
of funding new technologies. A lot of my
investing over the last, I would say three
to four years has been in various types of tech,
different products and services that I think will
overall help people to reduce carbon footprint.
I also donate money monthly to different causes
and companies including Charm Industrial,
which puts oil back underground. People
can check that out at charmindustrial.com.
And that, I believe, is now funded through,
as it stands for me, Terraset. I believe that is
how I'm going about doing this, Terraset Climate,
so people can look at that as a means, for
instance, to hopefully offset some of the
carbon footprint of my travel and other things.
I am intensely aware of individual action,
but also the necessity in a sense to, number one,
not try to consume our way out of this problem,
but also simultaneously to recognize
that we do need better technology. So
it's a combination of different things.
All right, this is a question from the
live feed. "What classical career are you
in a parallel reality?" This is Espanol327.
I would say neuroscientist or marine biologist.
Those were the two professions that I most wanted
to pursue after age, say, 12 or 13. Prior
to that it was comic book penciler. So I
would say those are my classical careers
as such that might exist in some parallel
set of universes or in the multiverse on other
tracks that are running parallel to this one.
Let me go to the questions that were
pre-submitted and I'll answer a number
of those and we'll bounce back and forth. So the
next question is going to be from Lucas. "Hey,
Tim, you mentioned in an interview that you
allowed yourself to live your life unoptimized.
Are you still living an unoptimized life?"
I would say that there's optimizing and
deoptimizing happening simultaneously
in the sense that there are certain
things that I am optimizing. To define
that simply tweaking variables to, say,
improve certain outputs based on the inputs.
Right? So looking for an elegant refinement in
so much as I might approach something like
Occam's Protocol in The 4-Hour Body, which
I've ended up following, again, roughly the same
as it was published in 2010 in The 4-Hour Body.
This is a strength training and resistance
training program. It's a very minimalist,
but in the last four to six weeks I've
probably gained 10 to 15 pounds of muscle
and lost a decent amount of fat in the process.
That's more diet-dependent than anything else,
the fat-loss side, and that would be slow-carb
diet. But when you're approaching say,
progressive resistance, you want
to follow the metrics very closely,
have some type of plan in advance so
one could argue that's optimizing.
But then there's deoptimizing, and if you look
at my kitchen table and the books strewn about,
including this one: Masterpieces of Fantasy
Art. This is a TASCHEN book, or a TASCHEN book,
Dian Hanson. This is a gift that was put in
front of me, to my glee, about two weeks ago,
and I've been digesting that very slowly. As I
have been digesting different types of philosophy
and poetry, which certainly I'm not trying to
speed read in any sense whatsoever and went for
a long meandering, relatively unplanned hike.
That is, the path itself wasn't predetermined
with my dog Molly earlier today. So those would
all be examples in my mind of unoptimized living.
But they go hand in hand. I don't think you can
really optimize any facet of your life without
perhaps strategically deoptimizing or neglecting
other aspects. I think it's beyond the reach of
most mortals to optimize everything. So it becomes
a question of trade-offs and picking and choosing.
Question from Zain. "Who is someone
you've been impressed with lately
that people may not know of, and why?"
I would say one that comes to mind is an
oldie but a goodie. This is a Chinese photographer
named Fan Ho, incredible photographer director,
multihyphenate, long since passed, as I understand
it. But Fan Ho's work is truly spectacular in
terms of the composition of the images. I think
all visual artists could learn a lot from Fan Ho.
So Fan Ho would be what comes to mind.
I'll do one more on the questions that
were pre-submitted from you all. This is from
Yavor. "Do you use personal coaching, and how?"
I have used a lot of personal coaching throughout
my life, certainly for sports, for dance, for,
let's just call it, executive coaching. I
would also check the box. I've worked with
Jim Dethmer at conscious.is, that's the Conscious
Leadership Group, and I recommend their book The
15 Commitments of Conscious Leadership, I believe
it is, which was initially recommended to me if
I'm recalling correctly, Dustin Moskovitz.
And there are many others that I have used
over time. So the short answer is yes. In terms of
how or why? I would say there are many different
breeds of coach. Some focus on offering strategic
advice. Others act as therapists in a sense,
ask you a certain set of questions. They tend
to each have their toolkits and they elicit
different types of thinking by asking questions
that you would not be inclined to ask yourself,
or perhaps respond to differently when you're in a
conversation. And then there are still others who
simply hold you accountable. Or I should say not
so simply, in all cases, hold you accountable and
they have other types of value that they offer.
But predominantly, say, for someone in my position
right now in this chapter of my life as it's
unfolding, I think that the greatest benefit
is having someone to stress test my narratives
and beliefs, which are sometimes so ingrained
that you simply see that as reality. But to
have someone who can identify, perhaps, the
beliefs that you haven't stress-tested, to really
break assumptions that need breaking or rewrite
narratives that need rewriting, number one.
Number two, to ask uncomfortable questions.
Number three, to act as an accountability partner,
because if you're at the top of the pyramid,
organizationally speaking, or if you're
a solopreneur or anything like that,
even if you're the CEO of a really large
company, if you're at the top and perhaps
you don't have as much accountability in certain
respects as you would like, I think a coach can
add a lot of value in that capacity.
So those are three of the questions.
I'm going to jump back now to the live stream
and see what else we have going on here.
All right. This is a question from Reed,
if I'm getting that right. "How have you
been working on your 'good enough' muscle?" Good
enough! Good enough is in quotation marks here,
and I suppose that's meant to underscore
my predisposition to being a perfectionist
and having some degree of OCD to contend with.
The good enough muscle is actually, I would say,
relatively easy to exercise if you recognize you
cannot optimize all things as I mentioned earlier,
and that it's a question of trade-offs. And much
like some friends of mine have said, you should
be, or strive to be, world-class in one or two
things. And for the vast majority of other things,
except that good enough is plenty good enough.
I would say that I'm trying to make faster
decisions, if those decisions are reversible
or very low cost. And then you can sort out
the details often later. So rather than
waiting or hoping or searching for an
additional 20 percent of information, let's just
say you're at 60 percent and you think you could
make a better decision at 80 percent. Well,
if it's very low-cost or reversible or both
making a fast decision and approaching it in
more of a ready, fire, aim sequence, I think,
makes a lot of sense. So that's part of how
I am approaching things, if that is helpful.
All right, somebody asked about the
video quality and the cam mic lighting
details of my current setup.
I have a Logitech Brio webcam,
reasonably inexpensive. I'd say it's
$70 or $80, connected to my MacBook Pro.
This is an ATR, I want to say 2100 microphone,
but it's probably the later gen. So an ATR,
maybe 2300 USBC mic from Audio-Technica. This is
probably also $70 to $80 bucks. And then in terms
of light, there is no special lighting aside from
the ceiling lights and the natural light coming
through very large windows in front of me. So that
is my fancy, fancy setup that fits in a backpack
and often travels with me in a backpack.
All right, this is a question from
Cranberry Leadership. "Hi, Tim. If
forced, how much of your success can
you directly attribute to studying overseas?"
Direct attribution is hard, but I would say that
certainly I do not think I would be sitting here
today with the trained ability, I don't think it's
innate, to ask questions about basic assumptions,
to poke at conventional wisdom, in quotation marks
and convention overall, had I not spent time
abroad. Especially my first year abroad as an
exchange student in Japan, given how alien and
unlike the US Japan is in almost every respect.
So I think that that has directly contributed
to my ability to operate in the world in the
way that I do. And I'm very grateful for that.
"Can we get a part three with Todd McFarlane?"
Quite possibly. Todd is always good. That's
from Moby, and I certainly wouldn't mind,
hopefully in person. I think that would be better.
What would I add to 4-Hour Body if I wrote it
today from a name that I cannot pronounce?
I would probably add a chapter on fasting. And
I would say Tools of Titans really was intended
to be almost an addendum to The 4-Hour Workweek,
The 4-Hour Body and The 4-Hour Chef
in terms of, say, healthy, wealthy,
wise, not necessarily in that order. But the
fasting chapters and also segments on mental
health and psycho-emotional health, health, and
psychedelics that were added to Tools of Titans,
I would say probably with some tweaks and updates
would have been added to The 4-Hour Body, or if I
revised it today, those would be added.
Okay, so here's a question from Antius,
if I'm saying that correctly. "Your vibe in this
place seems very intentional." That is the vibe
behind me. "Can you tell us more about why you
chose that vibe?" I'll leave the question at that.
Yeah. This is a very rustic country feeling
and it's also a place that is intended to be
lived in. So if you look at, for instance,
this wood behind me, this is going to be 20,
30, 40 years old, maybe 50 years old, the
floors, same. And I've made a few tweaks,
few upgrades here and there, but by and large this
is intended to be used, possibly abused. There's
scratches all over the table that I'm sitting at
with wine stains and so on from heavy social use
with friends and family. And this particular
spot where I'm spending time is intended to
be restful and easeful and part of that is not
looking like or being treated like a museum.
Also very sensitive to color palette and
natural light. So there's a lot of natural
light here and I love the colors of fall.
So you'll notice the backsplash behind the
range has a very autumn-themed palette to
it, and that is also very much deliberate.
This is a question from Christina.
"Have you ever had imposter syndrome
with a podcast guest? If yes, who and why?"
So I wouldn't say that I've had imposter
syndrome. I would say that there are times when I
have felt very nervous and insecure and have been
very worried about stumbling and making mistakes.
I think there are a few guests who come to mind.
Certainly my first episode with Arnold
Schwarzenegger, that was 2015 and that
took a year, a year and a half to set up.
Jamie Foxx. Similar, that took a year and a
half or two years to set up. And I put incredible
extended preparation into both of those episodes.
To give an example that may not be as
obvious as an A-list celebrity. Ed Catmull,
who at the time I think was president of Pixar,
he may have held some other official title,
but Ed was the first person I had on the podcast
who was both high profile and someone I had never
spoken with before. So we had no preexisting
rapport, no preexisting friendship, and I was
incredibly nervous about that, which is evidenced.
We may have cleaned it up, but as he spoke,
I was so nervous every time he said something, I
did what, in Japanese, I guess would be aizuchi,
which is like a confirmation like "Hm, hm, hm."
So this "Mm, mm, mm," like someone who's hungry
and looking at a plate full of delicious, hot
food drove people nuts. And it was a nervous tic,
which we almost certainly ended
up editing out significantly.
But I've never felt like an imposter, and I am
not sure why that is. I know imposter syndrome
and that term get used a lot. The idea that you're
going to be found out as a fraud or something like
that. But I've always tried to be very transparent
with my weaknesses and where I am in the learning
curve with everyone, including my audience. And
I think that prevents that or avoids it at least.
So if I am on the stage telling people that I
have A, B, and C weaknesses or that I lack D,
E, and F experience, and sometimes I
say that explicitly in my conversations,
it's almost like preemptive body armor in a
sense. Not only against external criticism,
but self-criticism. I don't need any additional
fuel on the fire for negative self-talk. So that
could be viewed as a way of bolstering my
confidence in whatever skills I might have
or in the skills that I'm developing by laying
it all on the table, if that makes any sense.
Why do I have a washing machine in the kitchen?
That's a damn fine question. It was in here when
I bought the house. I think it's ridiculous, but
it doesn't really fit anywhere else. So that is
why I have a washing machine in the kitchen.
I'll do a few more in the live stream and
then I'll go to the pre-submitted.
All right, it's from Joseph. "Any
plans to go backcountry skiing this winter?"
Absolutely. Lots of plans to go backcountry and
sidecountry skiing this winter since that is one
of my absolute favorite activities. So ski touring
probably on DPS touring skis, which I bought last
season and I am extremely excited. Could not be
more excited to get out and get amongst it.
All right, this is a question from Aaron.
"If you were to start your podcast/brand
over today, what would you do differently?"
These questions, this type of question is always
challenging to answer because the times, the
conditions have all changed and I have changed.
What I would say is I started my podcast almost 10
years ago, this upcoming April, it'll be the 10th
anniversary of the podcast. And when I started,
I would say podcasting was attractive for
the same reasons that angel investing were
attractive to me in, say, the 2007/2008 period.
And a few of those ingredients are number one,
it wasn't cutting, cutting, cutting edge. I wasn't
the first person to podcast. There was a certain
critical mass of, say, a thousand true fans, many
more certainly for shows like Rogan or Nerdist
or Marc Maron. So there was a proof of concept
already in front of me. I saw that something was
happening and gaining in momentum and power.
With the angel investing very similarly,
there were a lot of venture capitalists, a handful
of angel investors who were doing well. There
was this burgeoning new species of investment
vehicle or person, let's call it, who were deeming
themselves micro VCs at the time, but it was
otherwise pretty uncrowded. Ditto with podcasting,
relatively uncrowded easily to differentiate
myself and to establish a podcast that would
stand out from the crowd and be appealing to
my audience. And the ability to become the
signal above the noise was very, very high.
And as it stands right now, podcasting has
become much more crowded and I think that
it is something I would not pursue with the
same degree of conviction, or at least
it wouldn't seem obvious off the bat.
All right, this is a question from Chris. "How
is cutting back on booze going? Any advice
on how to set expectations with friends
who are particularly fond of drinking?"
Cutting back on booze is going really
well. I haven't had any in, I don't know,
a week or two and I'm planning on doing no booze
for all of October and the first half of November.
So it'll be minimum of six weeks with no booze
whatsoever. And in terms of setting expectations,
it's, I would say, number one, being up
front if I'm ever invited to go out that
I'm not drinking and I don't want to have a
big conversation about it. I don't want to
feel pressured. I am just not drinking right now.
And you could use an athletic goal as a pretext
for that. Say you're trying to cut down
on weight. Say you're trying to see how
it affects your HRV. You could certainly use
anything like that. You could say that you're
taking medication or supplements that
might be contraindicated with alcohol,
which is pretty much everything, by the way. So it
doesn't need to be a lie. It can just be maybe an
overemphasized minor truth in this case. All of
those approaches I think could work pretty well.
All right. Here's a question I get a lot,
actually. This is from Branislav. "Your face is
so smooth, no wrinkles. Do you use any particular
skin products or have you had any beauty
treatments like Botox or anything like that?"
No. I have not had any of those enhancements
whatsoever. And I have used Dr. Bronner's
unscented Castile soap, so large containers
of Dr. Bronner's unscented soap for pretty much
everything for years now. I refill my hand soap
with Dr. Bronner's and there are these devices
you can get on Amazon with mason jars that help
you to basically create foams doing this. So
you can put that in your bathroom or anywhere
else. And that is effectively all I use for
both my face, my head, and my body. And my
general approach with self-care is the fewer
chemicals, the fewer ingredients, the better.
This has been my policy for a long time. It's also
why I tend not to use sunscreens. Occasionally
I'll use something that is predominantly, say,
zinc oxide if I'm going to be in a very harsh
set of conditions, for instance, especially if I'm
on snow or anything that's going to be reflective
where I might get incredibly burned, then I
might use something like that. But otherwise
I will use long sleeve shirts, hats, et cetera
to minimize my sun exposure or take breaks,
right? I'll be exposed for 20 to 30 minutes
and then I'll take a break and I'll slowly
acclimate over time as opposed to putting
sunscreen with 30 ingredients on my skin.
We've seen recall after recall after recall,
for instance, of sunscreens based on different
carcinogens and so on. I'm not sure that's
helpful, but I will say that there is such a
thing as over applying chemistry and enhancements
to your body and your face. So I really try
to use a light hand and the less, the better.
I would also say that your external condition,
I think is often a reflection of your
internal condition. I do consume a lot
of healthy fats. I take Nordic Naturals omega-3
supplements. I alternate between fish and algae,
which has completely eliminated any type of
nausea that I have felt from other omega-3
supplementation. As an example, I pay a lot of
attention to diet, so I would say I'm working from
the inside out as opposed to trying to address the
cracks in the veneer with topical treatments. But
I get this question a lot, so I wanted to take
a stab at answering it. I also think that the
lighting and the camera are very flattering at the
moment. I do have crow's feet, large crow's feet.
All right, let's see. I have a question from
Big Dog. "Do you notice a pattern in your
happiness levels in regards to different
types of social activities, parties,
nightclubs, events, hiking, et cetera?"
I would say definitely I do. And for
this reason I try to schedule two guys trips
for me. So two guys trips per year at least,
which are generally in the six-to-eight-person
range doing something active. The last trip
was back and sidecountry skiing. I could
certainly see another option being hiking
or fishing or something that involves movement.
And group dinners. Group could be two or three.
I think the ideal number for me is probably
three to five, maybe even three to six as long
as people don't split off into side conversations
ideally. When I am in a city that makes that easy
to organize or a place where that is easy to
organize, I would say two to three times a week
seems to be the magic number, but even once per
week, honestly, ideally, say, Wednesday, something
like that, or during the week, which gives
me a booster shot of well-being from a mental
psychoemotional perspective to carry me then
through the rest of the week. Friday, Saturday,
Sunday, take care of themselves, especially
Friday, Saturday. So those are a few things.
Will had a good answer for the alcohol and
what to say to your friends. "I just tell
them I'm allergic to alcohol. I break out in
handcuffs when I drink." That's pretty good.
A question from — we've got lots of questions
now. Okay, that's because we have 1,382 people
now instead of 31. Okay. "Who do you want
to interview you haven't interviewed yet?"
There are so many people who come to mind. Ryan
Reynolds would be very high on my list. I would
really love to have him on the podcast, but TBD.
All right, this is from Hungarian Language and
Culture. "Have you ever thought about interviewing
Dan John?" I have thought about interviewing Dan
John, and thank you for the reminder. So I'm going
to write that down. I'm a big fan of Dan John and
Easy Strength and his work with Pavel Tsatsouline.
Certainly he would be an interesting addition
to the roster. So I will put that down.
This is from PJ. "Where in your creative
process do you feel the greatest friction
today? And what strategies from the top
one percent of creatives you've interviewed
have worked for you to help overcome them?"
I would say the friction honestly is feeling
fear around delving into new formats. That
could be screenplay, it could be comic
book writing, which I think is the most
likely next step for me. I think comics, and
I have The DC Comics Guide to Writing Comics,
something along those lines. Let me grab it.
The DC Comics Guide to Writing Comics right
here by Dennis O'Neil, which is
a great book by the way. And the
challenge for me is getting started. It's also
delivering something by a specific deadline.
In terms of the top one percent creatives and what
I have borrowed or find useful that I think could
help me get over this hump, frankly, it's being
accountable to other people. So I've brought in
others to help me with creative concept art
pushes, and I'm in the process of reviewing
various types of environmentals and backgrounds,
for instance, right now. And there are deadlines
for that. That helps push the ball forward.
With something like the comics, I think having,
for instance, an accountability partner or a coach
to focus on things like this so that if I do not
deliver, it's a matter of a very uncomfortable
conversation where they say, "Tim, you committed
to doing this by this point in time. You didn't do
it. You've hired me to help you with accomplishing
these things. What are we doing here?"
Honestly, and one of the questions I get a lot,
is when you're getting this advice
from four or five people per month,
what do you pay attention to? Do you have
FOMO about doing certain things and not other
things? How do you incorporate all the advice?
And frankly, there are times when I experiment
with new types of advice and then there
are times when I hit pause and I say,
"If I were to assume I know what to do, what
are the things I know I should do? What are
the things I know work?" Cold exposure,
resistance training, very basic meditation,
20 minutes twice a day. There are certain
ingredients that are easy to neglect because
they don't have the newness. They aren't the shiny
objects that have been put in front of me by a
guest who I admire and aspire to be more like.
Oftentimes it's not a question of figuring out
what to add. It's rather a question of looking
very closely at why you are failing to implement
the few things that you know reliably work and
then removing those impediments. All right,
you have resistance. There are certain
obstacles or things that are preventing
you from reengaging with these things. You're
doing them consistently. What are those? How
can you make them automatic? How can you look at
the work of say, BJ Fogg and perhaps James Clear,
Atomic Habits, so that you can build these things
into automatic behaviors like brushing your teeth?
And those are phases that alternate for me.
Right now I'd say I am not in the new habit
accumulation phase, but rather looking back over
my experience over the last five to 10 years, what
are the things that consistently work, that work
almost every time I implement them consistently?
And how can I return to those things?
All right, couple of other questions. Itzhak,
I apologize if I'm not pronouncing
that correctly. "Have you ever
learned about or studied the Talmud?"
I haven't directly. I'm very interested.
I'm interested in holy scriptures overall,
and I'm actually going to be taking time
over the next month to read a lot of these holy
scriptures. I think that it is probably impossible
to understand humanity as it has evolved or
changed over certainly the last 2,000 years,
3,000 years without, depending on
whose scriptures we're referring to,
without having some, at least basic passing
familiarity with these texts. So I will be taking
that time over the next three to four weeks.
Here's a question from David. This is about
language learning. "Tim, you've talked and written
so much about language learning, but not as much
about maintaining and revamping your languages.
I'm trilingual and working on language number
four, thanks in no small part to resources like
The 4-Hour Chef and feel that keeping up with
all my languages is often just as much work as
acquiring them in the first place. What practices
or processes, if any, do you have for keeping up
with your Japanese, Spanish, and other languages?"
All right, I do have some approaches here.
So number one is something that's become much
easier in the last handful of years, and that
is movies, watch movies. Not only watch, say,
for instance movies in Japanese, so Japanese
movies with English subtitles. Watch English
language movies with Japanese subtitles. And ditto
for Spanish, right? So watch English language
movies you know well, ideally, right? It could
be something you've seen a hundred times like
Die Hard or whatever, it doesn't really matter
with Spanish subtitles. And then conversely,
watch Spanish language movies with English
subtitles. Preferably that's something that is,
say, a series or a television show. I just find
there's a little bit more grist for the mill. And
you can get used to the speech patterns of various
protagonists and actors within a given series. So
I've done that with Spanish multiple times.
Another approach is linking them together.
So linking languages together. And what I mean
by that is if, for instance, you have learned,
in my case, Japanese first, when I wanted to learn
German, I bought both Japanese language versions
of One Piece, which is a very famous manga,
very famous comic book. I bought German language
versions of the same One Piece comic book, which
is a global phenomenon. Many people know it now,
but certainly back in 2005 this would've been less
common in German and then later in Spanish so I
could read the same series. And if I'm reading
the German and I don't understand a section,
rather than going to an English-German
dictionary or a German-English dictionary,
I'm going back to the Japanese and I'm using
the Japanese to learn the meaning of the German.
And by doing that, I'm reviewing my Japanese
while acquiring the German. And then later,
for instance, when I did Spanish, I used the
German language version of One Piece as my
safety net for the Spanish language version of
One Piece. So I'm reading it in Spanish. If I
don't understand something, I'm not going to
English, I'm not going Japanese, I'm going to
my most recent language, which is going to be
in that case German, if that makes any sense.
And what's beautiful about these comic books is
they are laid out page by page, pane by pane,
typically in exactly the same way. So the dialogue
should map really cleanly. And another benefit,
which I just alluded to for the comic books,
is that they are almost entirely dialogue.
Rather than exposition, dense prose that is
very literary in nature, almost all of it is
dialogue. And granted, they might be talking about
pirates or something else that's not going to fall
into your daily conversation all the time, but
a lot of it will and certainly the grammar will.
All right, that is language learning.
Okay, this is a question from Krishna. Molly pup.
That's Molly pup right there, my dog. "Can you
please share more on your daily care and routine
for Molly? We have a puppy and want to incorporate
best practices and diet plan and training.
Big thanks for everything you do."
Thanks for the question. So I do have some videos
on YouTube related to basics of dog training. I
am not the world's greatest dog trainer, but I
did spend a lot of time looking at different types
of training. As far as books go, I would strongly
recommend Don't Shoot the Dog by, I believe it's
Karen Pryor, who popularized clicker training
using clicker training, which she had initially,
I believe, refined with aquatic mammals who really
don't respond to negative reinforcement, right? If
you're training a dolphin and they don't do what
you want them to do, you can't really fold up a
newspaper and smack the dolphin on the butt with
"Bad dolphin." They just swim away. So you then
in turn get much better at positive reinforcement.
This is also true if you're say, trying to train
a chicken, which is something I still want to
learn how to do. I want to do a weekend course
in training chickens. And one of the quotes in
the book I remember, I can't remember the
attribution, but it was, "No one should be
allowed to have a child until they've been forced
to train a chicken." And there's a lot to it.
So if you want to learn about conditioning
overall, and certainly as it relates to a dog,
I think clicker training and Karen Pryor and
Don't Shoot the Dog are a great place to start.
There are some fantastic YouTube channels,
which I believe at least last I checked,
I referred to in the description and some of
my videos on the Tim Feriss YouTube channel.
So you can take a look at those, but there are
various types or categories of training. There's
safety, which should take precedence over, say,
kind of vanity tricks, right? Dog spinning around
less important than the dog staying, say, in
the back of the car and not jumping out until
you've issued a command that sort of releases
the dog to jump out because they could get hit
by a passing car or something like that.
In terms of routines, lots and lots of
walking. Breed by breed different breeds will
have higher demands. If they're working dogs
like a Border Collie, you really shouldn't
have that dog in an apartment in the city,
for instance. They just require way too much
exercise for it to be compatible with most
people in a heavily urban environment. But big
dogs, really big dogs, and really little dogs
do pretty well in those constrained environments.
Molly is kind of like her old man, me, a former
athlete, not great endurance, very heat
intolerant. So her enthusiasm outstrips
her capacity for work, which is great for
me because I can take her for an hour-long
or two-hour-long walk and I can either do
that in the wilderness or do it leashed,
usually attached around the waist and listen to an
audiobook if that's something that I want to do.
But I just swam laps in the pool before jumping
onto this Q&A in freezing cold water as a way
to wake up. And that is one of her favorite
activities. And she'll run around the pool
from end to end to end to end, basically
doing a shuttle run for the entire time
that I'm swimming. So a tired dog is a happy
dog. It's also true for humans, by the way. A
physically exhausted human is generally a happy
human, and a well-trained dog is a happy dog.
Now, well-trained could be substituted with
a dog with clear rules is a happy dog. And
I think that also applies to parenting
and kids, right? How consistent are you,
how predictable are you and therefore perceived
as stable? I think all of these things apply.
So those are a couple of recommendations, but
certainly when you look at Karen Pryor and
clicker training, I also think if your puppy
is young enough, crate training is one of the
greatest gifts you can give your dog. Do not give
your puppy the opportunity to make mistakes. It's
harder to remove behaviors than it is to prevent
them in the first place. So if you don't want
your dog to chew on shoes, just get shoes out of
their range. Get them off of the floor so they
don't develop that habit and they get past
that teething phase. And then you'll never
have a problem with your dog chewing shoes.
Here's one. Mary: "Do you batch cook?" Yeah,
I do. Especially if I'm by myself, I'll batch
cook and then I'll eat meals for a while. I
have been following the slow-carb diet, as
described in The 4-Hour Body. You can find
it online. If you just search "How to Lose
100 Pounds [on] the Slow-Carb Diet," there's
a blog post that I wrote that lays out all the
basics, and you don't need the book for that.
I've been cooking, for instance, chili. I have
chili in the refrigerator. Then, I cooked up some
95/5, so 95 percent ground venison, five percent
ground organs, Maui Nui Venison ground meat,
which is the most nutritionally dense
meat you can buy in the United States,
as far as I'm concerned. And they have the
analysis on the website to demonstrate just
how incredibly nutrient rich their meat is. And
their blends, especially with a bit of organ meat.
I'll cook that. And the combination of that,
plus the chili, plus a little goat cheese,
because you've got to have a little goat cheese,
plus some sauteed spinach, which was cooked at
the same time, that'll feed me for three or four
meals. And as someone who's currently flying solo,
I'm about to leave the country, that is
a fantastic go-to meal that I can just
recycle over and over again. I'll generally, I
would say, cook, batch cook enough to feed me
for four to five meals. And then, I'll go out at
least once a day to have the social interaction.
This is from Leif, L-E-I-F. "Are there
any global or national trends in the next
five to 10 years that aren't talked about
enough or you believe more people should be
paying attention to? If applicable, how are you
personally preparing for this or these shifts?"
I would say one that comes to mind is, for lack
of a better term, digital emotional surrogacy.
I'm sure there is a sexier or more elegant term
for this, but the inevitable development that we
will have, I would say, within the next, probably
two years, photorealistic avatars that we can
interact with through, say, virtual reality. And
if you haven't seen the demo of the Metaverse with
Zuckerberg with Lex Fridman on his recent podcast
on YouTube that showcases what this can look like,
I would encourage everybody to at least
watch the first five minutes to get a
taste of things to come with the ability
to interact with photorealistic avatars.
Furthermore, with the ability to interact
with photorealistic avatars who might be your
favorite celebrity, like a Taylor Swift,
with very convincing facial expressions,
we are getting to a point where companies
like Replika, for instance, Replika with a
K at the end, K-A instead of C-A, where digital
companions are going to become, for many people,
not just a supplement to human interaction,
but a replacement for human interaction.
I would say that the loneliness epidemic,
from my perspective, is probably only going
to get more nuanced, more complex and more
challenging to address, in some respects,
because especially for people like myself
who are introverts, I'm taking active steps,
so I'll answer that second part of your question,
to maybe preemptively gird myself for this.
But for those people who are already
intimidated or taxed by going out and
interacting with one person or groups of people,
you could see the case of, for many of them,
opting out completely. And I think we already
have problems with declining birth rates,
and there are many countries that are below
replacement rates at this point. I am very curious
to see what societal impact that will have.
The way I am counteracting that for myself is
booking things on the calendar in advance.
And by in advance, I mean, at this point,
I'm probably six months out booking trips, booking
time with friends, booking time with family,
getting it on the calendar, putting money behind
it. It doesn't have to be a lot of money, but
enough money that you can benefit from the sunk
cost fallacy and feel invested so you won't cancel
things. And really giving myself very few options
for opting out of social encounters I know,
social interactions that I've proven to myself
over time are always in my best interest. Even
if I will drag my feet to get there in the
first place, I will leave being better off.
Those are a few thoughts in terms of trends.
People are paying a lot of attention to, say,
AI, in broad strokes, or machine learning, in
broad strokes. But my interest, and certainly,
what I'm also watching in my audience are some of
the societal implications and the psychological
mass psychological implications of these things.
You will be able to take steps to perhaps put a
moat around yourself to minimize the damage,
but this is something to pay attention to.
And I would also say that, as these
tools become more and more convincing,
we've blown away the Turing test, it's already
been beaten or passed, so as these tools and
machines become more and more convincing, more
and more appealing, I think that there will be
the very natural impulse to offload more and more
of the things that we currently handle in our own
heads or manually. And if you want to preserve
some of those abilities, you're going to have to
decide to be, perhaps, a selective Luddite, or at
least for periods of time, be a selective Luddite.
For instance, how many people here would say their
parents are better at directions offline, not
using Google Maps than the younger generations?
And I would imagine a lot of people would raise
their hand. And this is perhaps not controversial
because people have decided to embrace something
like Google Maps or many other competitors to
help them with convenience and accuracy and so on.
However, if you don't use it, you lose it,
and it's easy to embrace convenience and not
recognize severe atrophy of capabilities
until it's very hard to reverse. I think
that that is a meta awareness that needs to
be developed as we are interacting with these
increasingly seductive and powerful tools. Long
answer, but these are things that I think about.
All right. Here's a question from Andre. "I'll go
on a longer trip to Japan next year and I would
love to know one of your favorite secret spots
in the country for a visit." All right. Here are
a couple of recommendations. And one will be not
so secret, but a lot of foreigners don't visit it,
and that's the Ghibli Museum. They call it Mitaka
Forest, but it is basically in Inokashira Park,
Inokashira-koen. You can get the tickets,
or at least, you could at Lawson convenience
stores. You could ask a hotel concierge
to also try to help you with this.
I believe there are now two locations. Ghibli
is G-H-I-B-L-I. It is effectively the Disney of
Japan. Miyazaki Hayao is figurehead behind Ghibli.
And my favorite movie, Spirited Away, is, I think,
their crowning achievement, but I'm biased. Ghibli
Museum. And Inokashira Park is also tremendous.
I would say, if you drink, Gen Yamamoto, so G-E-N,
Yamamoto, Gen Yamamoto is this tiny, tiny, I think
it seats six to eight people, bespoke cocktail bar
where you sit down, and it's basically omakase,
and the bartender serves you drinks. You don't
get to request things, you don't get to object,
you just get served, like a master sushi chef
would put things in front of you, various drinks.
And you have this experience, which is tremendous.
And I actually first met, I think it's Gen,
or Yamamoto anyway, at Brushstroke, I think
was the name of the restaurant in New York
City where I bumped into him. At the time, I was
doing the food marathon from The 4-Hour Chef,
for those people who remember that, where I
had whatever it was, 26.2 dishes in 24 hours
walking around New York City. And he was sitting
there with this ice pick and a number of tools,
chiseling huge blocks of ice into perfect
spheres to make his cocktails, and we struck
up a conversation. When a friend of mine invited
me to this place in Tokyo, I was sitting there and
after the first or second drink, we both looked
at each other at the same time and we're like,
"I know you." "I know you. Where do I know you
from?" And we put it together. There's that.
I would say there is a semi underground whisky
bar that is quite well known in Niseko, up in
the North. If you go skiing, I would certainly
take a minute and check that out. There can't
be too many of them. And it's a husband and wife
team. The husband is Japanese and the wife is,
I want to say Australian or British. I apologize
to her that I'm probably not getting it right.
It should be pretty easy to spot. And then,
if you can get to Nikko, N-I-K-K-O, in the
fall especially, but higher elevation, beautiful
rural area, if you can get there, it's amazing
for sightseeing, but they also have occasional
demonstrations of Japanese horseback archery,
which is yabusame, Y-A-B-U-S-A-M-E. And
if you have the chance to see that, you
should definitely see it. It will blow your mind.
All right. A question from Jane. "At one point you
talked about making the improvement of education
in our country a focus. Is that still an interest
of yours? And if so, what are your thoughts at
this time about how to do that?" Yes, it's still
of interest. I did shift my focus to mental
health therapeutics, including psychedelics,
for the last, let's call it eight years, but
education is always close to the front of my mind.
And I would say that I've shifted my focus in that
arena to not necessarily trying to fix policy and
so on, because it's beyond my capabilities and
above my pay grade. It's just not the arena where
I can make the most impact. By focusing on talent
sourcing, because there are often huge surpluses
of scholarships and funds that are made available
by giant foundations, but go unclaimed because it
is challenging in time to find the most promising
under-resourced kids in the country, period.
It's a talent sourcing problem. There
are organizations like QuestBridge,
which I've supported a lot in the past and feel
very strongly about. There are others that do
a lot of good in public schools with various
core materials and so on like donorschoose.org,
which I've been involved with as well. And
then, there are new startups that are doing very
interesting things with accelerated learning and
harnessing technology for that purpose. Certainly,
Khan Academy is interesting. Mentava is a very
new startup that I have backed, and fingers
crossed that they do a lot in that field.
This is a question from Andy. "Arthur C.
Brooks episode had an immediate impact upon my
life philosophies. Was curious whether it did
the same for you, if it had a big impact. You
two seemed to become fast friends. Thanks."
Yes, the episode with Arthur was a real delight,
and I appreciated his ability to spin many plates
very well. He is, from a secular perspective,
very dedicated to studying the science,
mostly on the social science side, but
certainly tries to tie that together with
neuroscience in the fields that he's exploring.
He is deeply religious, and I find that very
interesting. And I think the question of how
to create meaning more so than find meaning,
but you could use both, how to create meaning
in a world of pessimism and nihilism where, in
many countries, religion has fallen away, at least
in some of the more urban environments, is going
to become an increasingly pressing question. I am
personally focused on that. For me, individually,
but also as I just look at the different state
changes in various demographics in my audience,
it's very concerning. I do think about this a lot.
And I predicted, a few years ago, and we're
already seeing this, but it will continue to
be the case and will accelerate dramatically,
I think. There will be an explosion of what
you might consider new religions. Some of them
will masquerade as other things, right? CrossFit,
veganism, whatever it might be, but very strongly
held belief systems that are defended with
religious fervor where people who are heretics
from within are certainly ostracized. These types
of groups, some of them with overt spiritual
overtones or laws/commandments/intentional
living rules, whatever you might call it.
I think we will see a vast proliferation of
these things, as well as more uptake with the
Judeo Christian or Abrahamic religions. I think
all of those things are going to become more
and more appealing to humans, who, love it or
hate it, seem to be inextricably combined with
religion or the seeking of this thing called God.
And even in the most secular of societies, people
worship something. And I think the people who
are at most risk of self-deception and societal
problems are those people who aren't clear on
what they're worshiping. And this is barring from,
I think it might've been from Infinite Jest,
but everyone worships something. It's just a
question of knowing what you're worshiping. That
has certainly become of greater interest to me.
This is a question from Reese.
"Weightlifting for longevity. What are
your thoughts? What are you doing differently?"
I think, if you're going to choose one type of
exercise and one type of exercise only, resistance
training, which can sometimes take the form,
often takes the form of weight training, would
be the best investment for longevity and health
span. Certainly, for combating age related
decline of muscle mass and so on and so forth.
There were a lot of questions that have come
up in the pre-submitted questions around, say,
the slow-carb diet, weight loss, how do you
make weight loss sustainable? And a lot of
people have the experience of losing weight, and
then, regaining that weight. For instance, I'm
helping my dad right now with the slow-carb diet.
In the last, I want to say three months, he's lost
53 pounds, so he's doing really well. But those
gains, meaning those losses, are hard to hold
onto unless you upgrade your underlying machinery.
And what I mean by that is increasing muscle mass,
your mitochondrial engine, so to speak, such
that you have greater ability to dispose of
glucose. You have better ability, with this
enhanced machinery, to generate heat, to manage
your insulin and glucose response to food. Weight
training, really, we could look at the mortality
rates associated with broken hips and so on in
elderly populations. There's so many different
outputs from pulling the one lever of consistent
progressive resistance with, say, weight training,
that for me, it's just a no-brainer.
Yes, there are other things that you can
do and should do, probably, like zone 2 training
as described by Peter Attia. But for me, based on
all of the data, based on, certainly, surveying
my audience, seeing what works, what doesn't,
who's able to keep weight off, who's able to
sustain their progress over time, the common
factor that I've identified is weight training.
Now, why do I say weight training? Yes,
I said resistance training because you can use
something like gymnastic strength training, GST,
which is fantastic, but it is, in some cases, more
challenging to quantify the progress. Whereas,
if you're lifting dumbbells, 10 pounds
is 10 pounds, 12 pounds is 12 pounds,
15 pounds is 15 pounds. And in such a case,
it's really basic and very straightforward to
track your progressive resistance where you are
increasing the amount of weight or the number
of reps and increasing the productive stress
that you're applying to your system over time.
And I should note that that is another reason, why
if you have proper instruction, very, very key,
underline, underline, if you have proper technical
instruction, that free weights are often superior
to machines. If you're in one place and you
always will have access to the same machines,
feel free to use machines. But otherwise, in my
case, when I am traveling, a lot of the year,
dumbbells are, for instance, barbells are easy
to use anywhere I find them, and a pound is a
pound or a kilogram is a kilogram. That's a long
answer to a short question, but if I had to pick
one tool for longevity in the exercise bucket, not
on the diet side of things or in other categories,
I would choose, for myself, weight training.
All right. This is a question from Natalie. "Hey,
Tim. What have you learned from years of
interviewing around asking the right questions
and enabling meaningful conversations?"
I would say I've learned a whole bunch,
and I'll probably do a recap, if such a thing
is possible, around the 10-year anniversary
of the podcast because I feel like I've
learned a lot. In terms of asking questions,
I would say that an interview is very much like
a conversation. If you meet someone at a cocktail
party and your first or second question is, "Tell
me about the most traumatic experience of your
life," they're going to think you're a crazy
person because nobody communicates that way.
And there is a rapport-building, feeling-out
process, so I plan for that and I often will
spend, say, 10 minutes, five to 10 minutes before
we record having a conversation so that the guest
can feel more at ease with me so that we can then
get into some other corners. I will also set the
expectation in advance that they have final cut,
they have final edit, they'll get a transcript,
they can remove anything they want to
remove. I will also look out for them,
and for that reason, we should really explore
the edges. We should really push and let it
fly because I can always cut things out
later, but we can't add the interesting or
the unexpected back in later. That effectively
buys both of us permission to go places that
might not be typical for a conversation.
I always tell them where I'm going to start
so they build confidence in the beginning and no
one stumbles out of the gates. Also, I would say,
look for the side alleys. Realizing that my
podcast is not live, for instance, sometimes,
the digressions don't work. Sometimes,
the exit ramps that I think could take us
somewhere interesting don't work. But other times,
they really end up being incredibly important.
And one example that hops to mind is
my conversation with Debbie Millman,
my first interview of Debbie Millman. And some
of you will recognize that name also because she
and I had a conversation around childhood abuse
and our respective healing journeys from early
childhood abuse. And the reason I felt comfortable
going there with her personally, for my own story,
was that, when I first interviewed her, the list
of questions, all the prep was intended to focus
on her background in graphic design and her career
trajectory, but I had noticed that, whenever she
was asked about her childhood or her parents, she
would generally answer in one or two very vague
general statements and move on. And I thought that
was curious and I wanted to learn more about it.
I didn't suspect what was coming, but I
felt like at least we could cover some new
territory. And I asked her if she would
be comfortable, this is part of my five
to 10 minutes before we hit record, with me
asking her about her childhood. And she said,
"Well, maybe. We'll see. You can try. And then
I'll answer if I feel comfortable." I asked
her about this, and this was pretty early in the
conversation, I would say in the first half hour,
and it ended up being the first time she had ever
spoken publicly about childhood sexual abuse and
this incredibly traumatic period in her life and
everything she'd done to try to recover from that.
And that was the rest of the interview, right?
So I always try to take a shot at the odd question
or topic, maybe it comes up in my research,
maybe it comes up in the conversation where
there's a throwaway comment that might not be
a throwaway comment. And then I ask, "Well,
let's come back to that for a second. How did
that make you feel?" Some very basic follow-up
questions often to the trick. "What did you learn
from that? Walk us through that moment. What was
your internal experience? What was your self-talk
when A happened? Or when you did B?" These very
basic follow-up questions that take you off
script often lead to the most fertile ground.
And also in the first, I would say 10 minutes
or so, I try to ask questions that they have
never been asked before. Simply to
show based on my research with, say,
some very arcane point in Wikipedia that links to
another thing that links to another reference that
links to another reference and I get a quote from,
I'm making this up, but the second boss they ever
had when they were working at an ice cream shop,
and I asked them what their interaction was like
with so-and-so, or who was so-and-so and how did
they fit into your life? And they go, "Oh, wow,
okay. You really do your homework." And that snaps
them out of any autopilot dream state that they
might've accidentally slipped into or deliberately
slipped into. People who get interviewed a lot
have their 60-minute set just like professional
comedians because they learn what works. And I
don't blame them. I can do the same thing.
So those are a few thoughts on things I've
learned about interviewing. I could go on and on
and on, but those are a handful that come to mind.
All right. This is from Lexi.
"30 grams within 30 minutes,
a la the slow-carb diet or intermittent fasting?"
I'm still a 30 grams of protein within 30 minutes,
but I will say that that doesn't mean an
entire meal, necessarily. So I've been
waking up in the mornings, for instance.
I'll show you what I've been having.
I am going to sound like a bit of a broken record
here, but these are venison sticks peppered,
and they have between nine and
11 grams of protein each. This is
with 100 percent wild-harvested venison from
, like Maui as in the island, Nui, N-U-I. And
full disclosure, I mean I ended up loving these
guys so much that I invested in the company. But
that is not why I consume this. Three of these, I
can stick them in a backpack, that's my 30 grams.
And I will have these first thing in the morning,
then go for a walk with Molly for about a half
hour. That's when I'll have my first caffeine.
I'll sit down with The Five-Minute Journal,
which is something I've reintegrated into my
life, referring back to what I mentioned earlier
about taking the things that work and reapplying
them, ensuring you are doing them as opposed to
constantly adding the new, the new, the new.
So three of these sticks, go for a walk for
half hour, have my first caffeine, sit down,
Five-Minute Journal, get up, half hour back,
and then by that point I will probably have
some type of small meal. This will likely be
around 10:00 a.m., let's say, maybe a little bit
earlier. And then I'll postpone, that's probably
on the order of 400 calories to 500 calories.
And then I'll have my first real meal per se,
as lunch, let's call it at 1:00 p.m., something
like that. But I have just seen better results
for people with 30 grams within 30 minutes waking
up. It's very straightforward. It's very clear.
There's no gray area. And it seems to kickstart
the metabolic machinery in a way that is very
helpful for cognition, for sustained energy,
for a million different things. And there are,
if you follow the letter of the law per
se, very few ways you can screw that up.
With intermittent fasting there are a lot of ways
you can screw that up, and we don't have to get
into all of the ways. There are many people
who thrive on intermittent fasting, but there
are a lot of ways you can screw it up. And if you
look at, for instance, what I wrote in The 4-Hour
Chef and The 4-Hour Body, but especially in The
4-Hour Chef as it related to accelerated learning,
failure points, identifying the failure points and
removing as many failure points as possible. 30
grams within 30 minutes of waking up avoids dozens
of different possible dietary failure points and
body re-composition failure points as well. If
you're trying to maintain muscle mass and decrease
your fat mass, then I simply find this to be more
consistent for more people in what I've seen.
This is from a drummer. "What's your approach for
managing fear of death? I loved your practical
thoughts on suicide article from years ago. It
helped me through some tough times. Thank you."
You're very welcome. Yeah, if people have not
read that, if you're in a dark place, certainly
call a hotline, a suicide hotline if you need to.
But I do have a blog post about my darkest period
called "Some Practical Thoughts on Suicide,"
if anyone might find that helpful right now.
In terms of managing fear of death, I think that
my fear I need to manage is not fear of death,
it's fear of the descent to death. So losing
my health span, my cognition, my physical
performance. And I haven't really figured that out
fully to be honest, and maybe I never will. But in
terms of fear of death, I find Stoicism very, very
helpful. And I'll show you an oldie here. This is
literally, again, harkening back to rereading or
reintegrating the things that have worked. This is
a book from the Harvard Classics with Plato,
Epictetus, and Marcus Aurelius. I would say
Seneca certainly is a fantastic addition in terms
of memento mori, remembering you're going to die.
I find, and I'm not recommending this to all
people at all, but if you have what would be
described as mystical experiences and you can in
a sense assess these things with questionnaires
as they have done at Johns Hopkins and so on
with psilocybin-assisted therapies. When you
have these transcendent experiences where your
ego seems to dissolve, that could be through
psychedelics, it could be through any number of
different spiritual traditions and practices,
could happen spontaneously, could happen in
meditation and it often does in experienced
meditators or in some people the very first
time they try a new type of meditation,
they will have this experience of vanishing.
Having the self vanish for a brief period of
time. That was my experience the very first time
I did transcendental meditation, and then I spent
the next 10 plus years trying to get back to
that state. Which turns out to be pretty common.
But once you've tasted that, for me at least, it
begs the question is that so different from lights
out? Is it possible to then also be the observer
even when the self is extinguished? Is it possible
to experience what we consider consciousness even
without any identity to point to? And I think the
answer is yes. Also, as Naval Ravikant, I guess
has said before, he is like, "You remember what
it was like before you were born?" It's like,
yeah, like that. So since sitting here right now,
I can't say I was terrified before I was born,
maybe it is very much the same. And of course
there are infinite possibilities and every
tradition we can imagine has come up with some
working theory of what happens in the afterlife.
But for better or for worse, that is our sentence
as humans is to be aware of mortality. But those
are a few things that I have found helpful myself.
Very kind words in the comments. Thank
you, guys. I really enjoy doing this.
I'm thrilled that I get to do it and I
really appreciate you all being here.
This is from Carlos: "What exercises/techniques
work to get rid of your back pain after the
podcast episodes with Shirley Sahrmann, PT, PhD?"
There are a number of things that have been very
helpful. I'm still working on it, is
the short answer. But, there are some
portable traction devices that I found quite
helpful. Let me grab it, it's right next to me.
Because I have been going to a sports doctor
who uses a very sophisticated traction device,
but I travel so much I don't always have access
to this. So this right here is called Fisher
Traction, and it basically wraps around a door
handle and then goes around your waist and you
lay on your back and scoot yourself away to apply
traction. And then you relieve the traction every
five minutes or so and you do repetitions of
this. I just listen to an audiobook and/or hop
on the phone and do that. I found that incredibly
helpful for gapping a bit, especially on my low
back right side, say, between L5, L5 where I have
some stenosis and nerve impingement because of a
bulging disc. I have found focusing on internal
rotation and external rotation, very helpful.
That's something that Shirley underscored for me.
Definitely focusing on terminal hip extension when
walking. So ensuring that I'm pushing off of my
toe, in other words, ensuring that I'm pushing
off and getting that last bit of the stride as
opposed to pulling my leg forward with the hip
flexor. Instead of pulling it forward, stop. Pull
it forward, stop. I'm trying to push off and make
sure I feel that in my toe on each foot and then
have that leg swing through. And on top of that,
there are any number of different things
I could add to this, of course. But foam
rolling the piriformis and the IT bands and TFL,
I've found incredibly helpful. I use a Hyperice
vibrating foam roller, which seems to relieve
spasms much more effectively than other things.
And then avoiding certain things. So if I
sit on a very hard wooden chair, my QL, my
Quadratus Lumborum, and external obliques and so
on will spasm to try to support that area because
of the compression sensitivity. So I just have a
small pillow that I throw in my car. So if I go
to a restaurant, I'll just bring that in. Sounds
ridiculous. But for right now, it really, really
helps. Also, having proper chair ergonomics set
up. So even at this kitchen table where I'm doing
this recording right now, I'm sitting in an Aeron
Chair with lumbar support with some foot elevation
on the floor so that I have support instead of,
say, leaning forward on my elbows the whole time
and fidgeting back and forth in such a way that
causes the stabilizing muscles to light up and
then ultimately spasm. Hopefully that is helpful.
And yes to everyone who's asking, I have read the
Sarno books, I'm going to reread them, but not
all back pain is emotional or psychological.
Some of it is, absolutely. I'm going to reread
these things. The last year of my life has been
incredibly stressful from a relationship
perspective, especially having a five-year
relationship end roughly one year ago. And all
of the shifting sands that have come about after
that has been very, very challenging. I think
I doubled down on a lot as a way to occupy
myself to weather that storm, which I don't
actually view as a bad coping strategy. But,
it wouldn't surprise me if there are emotional
components. And I have very clear structural
biomechanical issues that also have some
explanatory power. And I do know doctors,
including the sports doctor I referred to earlier,
who are very close with Sarno and constantly
debated with him about these types of things.
If somebody gets in a car accident, suddenly
they have back pain they never had before, maybe
it's the car accident and not just their emotional
response to the car accident. And it's kind of
insulting to the patient, I think, to always
insist that it is in their head, per se. At the
same time, I would say that perception of pain,
pain patterning and psychoemotional health and
the stories we tell ourselves are seemingly very
intertwined. So I don't want to dismiss that. And
a lot of pain, I think, can be at least partially
explained with a lot of what Sarno describes.
All right. Let me take a look at a few more and
then I got to go because I'm actually, talking
about back pain, I'm going to a Pilates class.
And for those people who poo-poo Pilates,
if you work with someone who is very, very,
very technical and they're very good at addressing
the core, maintaining proper pelvis position,
it makes everything better. I'm just going to
say it makes everything, everything better. And
that goes for top athletes as well. Even if I were
at the peak of my competitive powers, one of the
things I would've said to myself 30 years ago was
do Pilates two or three times a week. It is going
to check a lot of boxes and cover a lot of bases
you are not covering and it will minimize the
likelihood of chronic pain and injury later.
A lot of people ask me for dating advice. I
don't think I'm in a position to give
dating advice. I'm not bad at dating,
I'm actually good at it. But ask somebody who've
dated around and then met the love of their life,
now they have three kids and have got all that
shit figured out. It's like, don't go to the
morbidly obese guy and ask him how to lose weight.
I mean, I'm not saying that's who I am equivalent
wise in the relationship realm, but the proof is
in the pudding. So I would say maybe listen to
Arthur C. Brooks and other folks on that more.
Although I will say that in this modern age,
it is uniquely bizarre to date with digital tools
and apps and also all of these social dynamics at
play, especially in the United States. It is
fucking insane. So there is that, but I'm not
overly concerned about it. I'll figure it out.
All right. What else do we have here? All right,
guys, my favorite movie of the last two years?
I'm thinking about rewatching actually one
of my favorites, too, Spirited Away, which I
mentioned already. And then also A Prophet or
Un prophète. It's a French film. I won't ruin
it by telling you anything about the story,
but it is beautifully shot. Also, quite brutal.
But it is a hero's journey par excellence in
a very modern setting. So people can check
that out if they would like to check it out.
This is a pre-submitted question from
Chris. "What is one book you love that
was better the second time around and why?"
There are many, but I would say that On Writing
by Stephen King, you really can't read about
fiction until you've tried some fiction. So once
I tried my hand at more fiction in the form of
The Legend of CØCKPUNCH, if you guys have no idea
what that is, you can Google it, then it meant a
lot more to read, say, Anne Lamott's writing or
the writing of other writers on the craft of
fiction. Also The Moral Letters to Lucilius,
the letters of Seneca, if you want to find those
for free, you can just search The Tao of Seneca
and I put together a bunch of PDFs with fantastic
artwork and calligraphy and so on because there's
a lot of overlap in the Stoic and Buddhist
philosophies and belief systems, and I wanted
to highlight that. So if you just Google Tao of
Seneca, you'll find a bunch of PDFs for free.
Here's one more from Shelby. "How do you break
negative self-talk?" I would say gratitude
practice. Easy way to embrace that is using
something like The Five-Minute Journal. And DBT,
dialectical behavioral therapy, I think
is undervalued, underutilized, and very
impressively systematized in a way that lends it
to scientific study, which is incredibly rare and
impressive in a world where psychiatric tools are
notoriously squishy and hard to evaluate. So DBT
would also be on the shortlist. And I would say
if you wanted something that is very graspable,
The Work by Byron Katie and turnarounds, she
has worksheets available for free online is
incredibly, incredibly helpful. Continues
to be helpful for me personally as well.
All right guys, I'm going to go do some
exercise, I encourage everyone to do the
same. And I appreciate you all tuning in.
Hopefully this was helpful. And I recognize
that a lot of people are feeling the specter
of uncertainty. Doom scrolling certainly does
nothing but pour gasoline on the fire of fear
and doubt. So monitor your information intake,
consider a low information diet and recognize
as well, as evidenced by the live chat here and
a lot of the patterns in the live chat, you are
not alone. Every human is uniquely endowed with
superpowers and super weaknesses and everyone
is fighting a battle, fighting struggles that
you know nothing about. So rest assured that
you are not alone in experiencing those things.
So "Kia kaha," I would say, stay strong, and I'll
talk to you guys soon. Thanks for tuning in, guys.